So, here's a summary of what we learned over the last two quizzes. We found a
general expression for the sum of two cubes and a general expression for the
difference of two cubes. We can see here that each of these factorized forms has
a binomial, a polynomial with 2 terms, multiplied by a trinomial, a polynomial
with 3 terms. The binomial that's involved in the factorization of each
expression, has the same sign between its two terms, as the original expression
did between its two terms. So, y cubed plus z cubed has a factor of y plus z and
y cubed minus z cubed as a factor of y minus z. The middle term of each
trinomial, each quadratic expression, has a sign opposite that original sign
between the terms. See we have a minus yc in the adding up the cubes and plus yc
in the subtracting. Other than that, these factorizations are the same. So, now
that we have this wonderful general framework for dealing with the sum and
differences of cubes, let's put it into action. Let's look at the expression x
cubed minus 8. Now, compared with the general equations that we were looking at
before, what in this case is playing the role of y, and what is playing the role
of z?